a warning now from the better business  bureau be careful what you share over  the phone that goes for pretty much  anything  from 2018 to 2019 the organization says  complaints about a fake irs  call they dropped about 89 but now  scammers are pretending to be from the  social security administration  in this case the caller is going to say  something about fraudulent activity and  then  ask for money better business bureau  staff say these kind of calls jumped  410 percent last year and could continue  this year  i'd be surprised if most people don't  get a call from somebody pretending to  be social security in the next couple  months you really got to watch out  scammers can spoof phone calls so it  looks like they're from the social  security  however the department is never going to  ask you for information and social  security numbers are  never suspended